it has made its reputation as the go-to
machine for video and photo editing but
as a long time pc user i gotta admit i
was a skeptic
then the mac studio arrived and i was
asked to not just to try it out but to
see what this could possibly bring to
the table so i gave it a shot and
honestly it blew through everything i
threw at it and we're talking about 3d
renders premiere pro exports
multi-window viewing and photo editing
let's talk about why the mac studio is
great for creators i've been a
professional video editor for about
seven years now both commercially and
now for our youtube channel and i've
doubled on all major analys from final
cut to premiere pro and to davinci
resolve and i still feel that premiere
is still the fastest and most efficient
editing software for my needs now of
course final cut only supports macos but
our studio and editors use adobe suite
and premiere pro so it's it's much
easier to just hand over projects when
necessary honestly it helps prior to the
mac studio i was using a windows based
pc 32 gigabytes of ram rtx 3070 ti and
let's just say very fancy rgb lighting
huh it's where i did all of my work get
to devil in a little bit of gaming as
well and for the most part it does its
job very well and i was content now i'm
gonna keep it pretty agnostic here
because comparing the mac studio to my
current pc setup just doesn't make sense
even at the mac studios base level m1
max it would outperform my current setup
but i was not prepared for what i was
about to experience here's why point one
the mac studio is a great choice because
this is pretty much it it's compact it's
small and i'm just surprised at how much
performance it packs in this small shell
compared to my editing rig now for those
who owned a mac mini or even that odd
looking trashcan
cheese grater mac pro back in the day
this design is what apple should have
done years ago
don't fix what isn't broken and because
it's so small and so portable it can fit
in my backpack or even my travel case
throw in a portable monitor and boom
you're set so if i needed to bring my
work with me i can
and i did yes i had the rona and i
brought this back with me during
isolation so that i could work how crazy
is that
having to work but it just amazes me how
small it is for a pro desktop machine if
i'm bringing this over to the geekbench
from my desk
was a breeze speaking of which desk
space is such a commodity these days and
i gotta tell you i was able to fit both
my desktop pc and the mac studio on my
desk which includes all the peripherals
including 4 displays talking about being
over the top
point number dos connectivity if you
ever had issues having more ports on
your macbook or imac the mac studio has
solved all those problems it's pretty
much the all-in-all digital content
creators dream when it comes to
connecting with other devices and
equipment like xeno over here
photographer cinematographer he's going
to have a ball of a time by how the sd
card slot sits right in front for easy
access i'm having a ball over time but
how the sd card slot sits right in front
for easy access see what i mean yeah
alongside that are two thunderbolt 4s
which is exclusive to the m1 ultra trip
model and at the back we've got a
whopping 4 thunderbolt 4 ports more than
enough to connect multiple monitors and
drives got to tell you it's got more
ports are than psa that was zenious joke
by the way yes you also have two usb
type a's and a hdmi 2.0 port that
outputs at 4k 60hz basically if you
wanted to you could support up to five
displays four of them over usbc and one
over hdmi now i've tested this with four
monitors
i got it that it's it's it's pretty
crazy if you thought two monitors were
enough for video editing which you try
for i've got one for the main timeline
on premiere pro the other one for colors
and effects another one as my reference
monitor and a small and portable monitor
so that i can watch my korean dramas yes
i watch korean dramas
it's nice which goes perfectly into
point number three performance the mac
studio and the m1 ultra is undoubtedly
the most powerful machine i've had the
chance to use in my career and of course
there are divided thoughts about it but
if you take a look at apple's track
record the apple m1 silicon graphics
performance has been at the top since
day one and the reality is if you're
watching this you are already
considering this for your studio or home
office for creative work that means you
artists you designers new video
professionals and creatives alike we all
know too well that videos are getting
heavier 4k 6k 8k workloads prores raw oh
my god now i won't bore you with any
grounds or data as this is more of a
consumer experience point of view but be
sure to check out the links and
references in the description below what
i can tell you is that running premiere
pro has been a smooth sailing experience
since it can run natively with apple
silicon compared to my windows based pc
the max duo has had no system crashes no
stability drops and just runs very well
on 4k playback is also very smooth even
with 8k prores footage and there were
times where i had to downscale it to
maybe just about half to a quarter
playback resolution but other than that
i've never had to use proxies on my
timeline even after adding motion
graphics and color grading
now everyone knows how adobe suite can
get really wonky on a pc and constantly
having to fix various software hiccups
before they could
really do their job okay we all know
that yo
god
[Music]
so the max studio takes the win here and
the max studio is shockingly quiet even
during heavy rendering in after effects
and even on blender
point four it's all part of the
ecosystem
one of the best things about owning
apple products is that it's all
connected if you own other devices like
an iphone ipad and even accessories like
the apple watch and airpods
it just works okay there's no denying
that it works the apple ecosystem
basically includes every product they
made but it's not just hardware alone
apple has designed their software to
make it easy for users to access their
photos music contacts and more my
favorite feature is of course airdrop i
love airdrop so airdrop is where your
devices can send files between each
other through wifi sharing now i use it
very often to send footage from my phone
to my mac studio and back and forth to
edit vertical videos and post them on
our social media platforms this is
probably one of the biggest game
changers for me switching out from
windows to apple imagine having to
transfer photos and videos back and
forth using a thumb drive or portable
hard drive or even google drive that's a
lot of drives but you know what i'm
trying to say is that it's enough to
break your concentration with that it
goes to my final point point number five
value overall i think it is important to
look at the entire apple ecosystem if
you're planning to get any apple device
because the ecosystem works but requires
an investment and commitment and people
may get sucked into the apple ecosystem
without knowing it
now the mac studio is going to be great
for creative professionals it's going to
provide you with the blazing performance
for creating content and if you're
willing to pay the higher price for the
smooth and seamless integration that the
apple ecosystem offers then yeah yeah it
actually makes sense now i would suggest
comparing apple devices via the website
and see what works for you in most cases
i would recommend the mac studio with
the m1 max chipset instead as a more
budget friendly option for those who are
not going to tap as much of the
horsepower that the m1 ultra provides
but there's also the 2022 macbook pro
and the macbook air for more portable
solutions and i get it there isn't a
one-size-fits-all solution here but
apple's got you covered with that
extensive lineup so do check it out with
that said we're gonna wrap up the video
thank you so much for watching do give
us a like and subscribe follow us on our
socials and be sure to check out all our
other amazing videos right here anki
culture
check it out
it's great content
we work hard to do this stuff you know
it's hard work it's hard work